with disney plus finally bringing
moonlight to tv screens it's time to ask
what do you really know about the avatar
of honshu whether it's his origins as a
villain or the tv show his alter ego
developed for himself here is the untold
truth of moon knight moon night suffers
from dissociative identity disorder once
known as multiple personality disorder
rather than the usual heroes every man
dichotomy we're used to with superman
and clark kent or spiderman and peter
parker moon knight has at least three
civilian names voices in your head
there's taxi driver jake lockley
millionaire steven grant and finally the
mercenary mark specter while he plays at
using the personas simply as covers and
tools it's clear even in the very
beginning of moon knights that they're
much more the three identities not only
speak and act differently but different
people in moon knight's life also choose
who they believe is a dominant persona
moon knight's love interest marlene for
example is in love with stephen grant
and always refers to him as stephen
whether he's wearing his mask or not but
the name co-creator doug mensch sora's
marking moon knight's dominant persona
was mark spector and spectre's name came
from an employee in a manhattan comic
book shop mensch couldn't remember the
name of the store when he told the story
but he did say it was the best comic
book shop in manhattan at the time mench
said he often used the names of people
in his life for new characters and a
comic shop employee named mark spector
asked him when mench was going to name a
character after him at the time mench
was working on an issue of werewolf by
night with a villain he needed a name
for and so the real life specter got his
wish
mentioned artist don perlin first
brought moon knight to life in 1975's
werewolf by knight issue 32 and he was
no selfless defender of the innocent or
avatar of honshu mark spector was a
mercenary hired by a clandestine group
known only as a committee to capture
jack russell the man cursed to transform
into a werewolf on knights of the full
moon it was a committee who gave spectre
his name his costume and even silver
gauntlets and the silver truncheon
specifically designed to hurt the savage
werewolf by the end of werewolf by night
issue 33 moonlight showed at least a
hint or two of the hero he would become
while he fulfills his contract by
capturing the werewolf and bringing him
to the committee the accusing please of
russell's friends and the desperation of
the captive werewolf convinced him he's
on the wrong side he frees the werewolf
from his cage and helps him escape still
he doesn't exactly come off like
superman the last time we see him in
werewolf by night issue 33 moon knight
is crouched on a roof ledge and
triumphantly holding up a stack of cash
he lifted from the committee
dementia's surprise marvel editors kept
asking him to do more with moon knight
so the character he'd created as nothing
more than an antagonist for a werewolf
comic started turning up in guest
appearances in spectacular spider-man
defenders and marvel two-in-one then
mench was tapped for writing duties on
the black and white hulk magazine which
eventually included a seven-page backup
feature starring moon knight ultimately
mentioned artist bill senkovic who had
jumped aboard during the hulk backups
were assigned the first monthly
moonlight title mint wrote a new more
heroic origin story for the hero
connecting him to egyptian myth and
solidifying mark specter as a mercenary
seeking redemption while the first
volume was cut after 38 issues it
enjoyed the honor along with keizer of
being one of marvel's first direct sales
comics in 1982 more comics were
appearing in comic book specialty shops
and fewer were being sold in newsstands
grocery stores pharmacies gift shops and
toy stores there was a push to cut out
distributors and sell directly to
specialty retailers and moon knight and
kazaat with marvel's flagship titles for
that push comic book fans still argue
whether the move to the direct market
was a good one but for mench and
cincovitch it meant more royalties
because they didn't need to sell as many
copies for the comic to turn a profit it
also meant more work since the comics
were printed with only in-house ads and
the creative team had to turn in 25
pages of story every issue instead of
19.
artist bill sinkovic whose unique style
is as recognizable as it can be jarring
began his comic book career drawing moon
nights tsinkovic was a second year art
student when he brought a portfolio to
the offices of dc comics but it
unknowingly picked precisely the wrong
time to try and join the dc team the
comics company was going through rough
times and was about to cut loose many of
the artists it already had still
syncovich's talent was evidence so
batman artist neil adams whose art
syncovich readily admits he based his
early work on called jim shooter at
marvel comics and told the controversial
editor-in-chief he had a new artist for
him both cinco vich and mensch guessed
it was at least in part the comparison
to adams and to the enduring industry
opinion that moon knight was marvel's
batman that paired cinco vich and mensch
regardless zinkovic proved his talent
and moonlight readers watched the
artist's work evolve into something
closer to the distinct style that made
the artist such an integral figure in
franchises like daredevil new mutants
and legion
according to mench cinkovic had trouble
meeting deadlines on moon night editor
dennis o'neil's solution was to tell
mench to write a seven-page backup story
that o'neill would give to another
artist then that backup would be ready
for some month when cincovich absolutely
needed it to meet the deadline according
to mench once he wrote the backup called
hit it o'neal screwed up instead of
sending the backup to a different artist
he sent it to shinkovich zinkovic told
mench hit it was the best thing he'd
written and the artist was convinced
that using larger panels and other
methods he could stretch it into a full
length story he succeeded and submitted
hit it as the main story for moon knight
issue 26. unfortunately he turned in the
pages so late that o'neal called mention
to the marvel officers from his home in
pennsylvania to script the pages at a
closet sized room with a typewriter hit
it was about a man randomly attacking
every person he meets and readers
eventually learn the criminal's violence
stems from severe childhood abuse
zinkovich suffered his own trauma from
childhood which at least in part
explained his drive to turn what was
supposed to be a seven-page story into
something else moon knight issue 26
marked the emotional end of the series
for cincovich though he stayed on for
four more issues and drew the covers for
the remainder of the series
before our moonlight series was
announced as part of phase 4 of the
marvel cinematic universe there have
been noise about an adaptation for years
the name mark specter was mentioned on
an episode of the short-lived blade the
series then marvel studios partnered
with no equal entertainment to develop a
show based on the hero the series never
came to fruition however nor did
long-running rumors claiming moon knight
would be added to the list of critically
acclaimed marvel netflix shows i'm not
seeking penance for what i've done
father
i'm asking forgiveness
for what i'm about to do
similarly key players of the marvel
cinematic universe and netflix marvel
shows toyed with the idea of getting a
moon knight adaptation made one such
person is guardians of the galaxy
director james gunn he tweeted in
january 2017 that while his workload
prevented him from making a moonlight
film he floated a premise for it past
marvel studios additionally netflix
daredevil showrunner stephen s denite
told ign in 2018 that he'd be interested
in working on a moon night show if his
schedule allowed for it
moonlight may be the first jewish
superhero though the mata is up for
debate mench told charlie huston he
created the first jewish superhero
though he also says he didn't begin with
that in mind after naming moon knight's
mercenary alias after a comic book shop
employee mench later learned the real
life mark specter was jewish so he
reasoned spectre must be a jewish name
whether or not moon knight is the first
jewish superhero depends on several
things including how you define first
jewish superhero ben grimm also known as
the thing of the fantastic four predates
moon knight by a decade though it wasn't
revealed he was jewish until the 2002
issue of fantastic four there's also doc
samson who first appeared in a 1971
issue of incredible hulk but his jewish
heritage wasn't discussed until the 1990
issue of the same series then there's
magneto and there's more heroic children
scarlet witch quicksilver and polaris
those characters and a whole host of
other superheroes in and outside of
marvel were created without their
heritage being mentioned but were later
confirmed to be jewish whether he's the
first jewish superhero is a matter of
debate but the notion that he's the
first openly jewish superhero is solid
in a very interesting retcon regarding
the origins of moonlight's weapons and
equipment it turns out that the west
coast avengers gave the superhero a
crucial early lift by a member of the
team hawkeye in 1987's west coast
avengers issue 23 the la-based team went
back in time to ancient egypt once there
they found worshipers of the moon guard
honshu the god moon knight serfs and the
siege determined to help the egyptians
defend themselves hawkeye designed
weapons for them like darts and
boomerangs the issue ends with a cut
back to modern times where we see mark
specter finding the same weapons his
fellow avenger designed the origin of
the weapons is another example of how
different writers and artists helped
shape the history of moon knight
hilariously one person who actually has
gotten a moon knight adaptation off the
ground where many others have failed is
none other than mark specter himself
issue one of brian michael bendis and
alex maliev's 2010 moonlight comic book
series debuted legends of the honshu a
television series within the comic
developed by spectre the show very
loosely adapts his adventures as a
mercenary along with some of his
exploits as moon knight he wasn't overly
concerned about getting all the facts
right which leads the show to take some
major liberties that included naming the
fictionalized spectre after mark's cab
driver personality jake lockley neither
the moonlight costume nor name was used
at all presumably to keep mark's
superhero life a secret from the public
while some characters had high
expectations from the series the
majority of the people working on
legends seemed to hate it the big
exception to this was mark himself
though even he became frustrated by the
show's numerous production issues
despite itself however legends of the
honshu became a success for a short
while anyway at the end of bendis and
believes 12 issue series spectre learns
from his assistant annie that legends
has been cancelled after a very short
time on the air ultimately it just
wasn't profitable enough
luckily the winding road to a moonlight
adaptation has finally ended thanks to
disney plus debuting on march 30 2022's
moon knight limited series brings the
fists of honshu smashing into the marvel
cinematic universe marvel studios has
made it clear that faithfully adapting
the character is a priority this is
represented in the series trailers tv
spots and posters confirming spectre's
disassociative identity disorder and
ties to honshu as major elements
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
similarly the series central villains
arthur harrow and anton moghat are also
straight out of the comics harrow is a
physician obsessed with studying pain
mogat is a midnight man an art thief who
dresses similarly to moon knights
headlining the disney plus series is
oscar isaac who assumes the role of
marvel's moon-themed vigilante is of
course no stranger to big franchises or
comic adaptations having played poe
dameron in the star wars sequel trilogy
and n sabaner in x-men apocalypse
furthermore isaac is a comic book fan a
graphic novel he's collaborated on head
wounds sparrow premieres june 21st 2022
he has expressed a deep affection for
the disney plus moonlight series and is
quoted as saying that it's his baby
of course once any major new hero enters
a marvel cinematic universe it's only
natural to ask if they'll join earth's
mightiest heroes while kevin feige has
called avengers end game the final
avengers movie the team is still clearly
active they even approach xiang chi
during the credits of xiang chi and a
legend of the ten rings moreover jeremy
slater show runner of the moonlight
series has said he'd love to see mark
spector's costumed alter ego join the
avengers as fans of moonlight's comic
appearances know the character has been
on multiple avengers teams starting with
the fan favorite west coast avengers
could he be part of a new avengers team
based out west or will spectre's time as
one of the secret avengers be adapted
into marvel cinematic universe history
instead alternatively he could simply
become part of the already existing
avengers team that is if valentina
allegra defontaine doesn't come to him
first to recruit her for her mystery
super team suffice to say moon knight is
not short on options
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]